reparieren
[Musik]
er repariert das lavabo er hat das
lavabo repariert weinen
das mädchen weint
das mädchen hat geweint trainieren
er trainiert im fitnesscenter
er hat im fitnesscenter trainiert
streiten die politiker streiten die
politiker haben gestritten
heiraten sie heiraten in der kirche sie
haben in der kirche geheiratet
heiraten sie heiraten auf dem standesamt
sie haben auf dem standesamt geheiratet
streiten die kinder streiten sie haben
um das spielzeug gestritten
trainieren sie trainiert im
fitnesscenter
sie hat im fitnesscenter trainiert
weinen er weint er hat vor schmerzen
geweint reparieren
er repariert das velo
er hat das velo repariert